I think people tend to forget that I
mean because I played 16 for so long
they forget that I am 23 Ciara Ramirez
is all grown up I'm kind of very
becoming very comfortable in Who I am
and what that means I'm kind of taking
it day-by-day just to find out the
person who I'm gonna be just yeah just
very positive about the future the
future looks bright for the young latina
who invited et into her Los Angeles
apartment for a candid conversation
about her next chapter but first a walk
down memory lane so there's a little
video lurking online of an adorable 10
year old singing at Showtime at the
Apollo
[Music]
so what goes through your mind when you
see this little cutie on stage singing
her heart out I mean I just I remember
this day so vividly you do yes find in
New York with my family and I remember I
mean this is such an iconic show and
that audience it's just no joke like
alright just praying please don't let me
fail and ya know it was just I had so
much fun once I was up there I kind of
blacked out and I just had my life
[Music]
what would this 10-year old Sierra think
of where you are today and everything
that you've achieved I don't know I
think she'd be really proud this has
gone beyond my wildest expectations in
the dream so yeah I'm pretty I'm very
happy about that the Fosters was such a
success five seasons what did that
experience mean to you it was a very
topical show you know yes very
groundbreaking in its own way so to be a
part of it was awesome and I learned so
much just you know growing up telling
these stories and so I'm just very happy
to have been able to give a voice to a
lot of you know those groups of people
Jennifer Lopez was your executive
producer no big deal there when I first
saw her I was on set I think I was
eating a sandwich and I saw a big group
of people and I just thought to myself I
was like okay someone over there is
important and so I just go back to
eating my sandwich and I look back and I
dropped it and I was like a whole family
yet but you know what's weird was it
wasn't like initially it wasn't oh my
god it's JLo I was like oh my god it
Felina a true thing oh yeah what does
she mean to you as a Texan especially
yeah I mean she's everything
and again a lot like JLo she's just
something or someone that I've just I've
always looked up to I heard about the
series that's happening I'm so excited
about that are you tossing your name in
the Hat I haven't but who knows I'd be
I'd be very happy to do that I mean you
have Texas you have Mexican American you
work with Jennifer Lopez I mean I like
where your head's at all the body I mean
I would be down 107 for now Sierra is
focused on her foster spin-off series
good trouble it's set five years in the
future
I mean picks up a couple weeks left
after the series finale so it's really
nice to see where all of your favorite
characters have kind of gone in their
lives and you'll kind of see them in a
different light everyone's very grown up
and kind of becoming their own humans
for sure Sierra says working with her
best friend Maya Mitchell again has been
a huge blessing what is it about her
that you just love and adore so much
yeah she's the yin to my yang
we're like if you need us as individuals
we are the complete opposite but we make
so much sense together
I mean I can't believe that you both
showed up for an audition you booked the
job and you wind up you really get like
a sister out of the job yeah I got
really really lucky and to be able to
continue to work with her has just been
a huge blessing
don't give up as much as we love Ciara
the actress we love Ciara the singer
people are used to seeing you as a young
girl and you're really kind of just
being sexy and owning your sexuality to
be a part of the kind of this next
generation this this next wave of women
where we're just yeah like taking our
power and and saying hey you know what
you can say it what I can - I'm really
excited about my new project because I
think it is an aside that people have
never seen of me it's a lot more
personal this time and I'm excited
personal hell just lyric cool wise and
everything like that and you know I'm 23
again so it's it's you know I feel like
I have some stuff to say for sure what
are you writing music about love life
you know kind of everything in between
what can you tease about an album are
you dropping something in 2090 mm 2019
early 2019 you can expect something from
me it's a lot different than the stuff
that I put out before it's a lot more
pop urban yeah I'm excited
can you tease collaborations or people
that you've been working with I have
been working with an amazing duo named
Co city
I mean I am a Latina so we gotta have
that that little Latin Flair so we're in
the process of that too as for her
personal life Sierra recently became
single and she says she's never been
better I learned to love myself again
100% I think you know like once you step
out of something you kind of go back to
basics and I really something that
helped me was just really like putting
my all into my career and just like
putting myself first and I think that it
can kind of you can get away from that
like when you're with someone not in a
bad way at all but you know you just it
was it was all about me again and I was
like you know what I'm gonna become the
boss lady that I want to be is marriage
and kids in the picture feel 100% I want
to name my kids after rockstars Axl's a
good one I like Hendrix Etta Stevie oh
so you're gonna oh yeah no I don't know
Wolfie you will see whatever I'm blessed
with but I got some names you're 23
where do you see yourself at 30 I would
love to have my own production company
maybe even you know I'm bigger in music
have some artists of my own that I'm
helping oh I think that could be really
fun just taking it day by day but I do
have some you know some hopes and dreams
for sure
[Music]